Maintaining
good mental health is
a mixture of boundaries
and doing things
that bring you joy.
This is embarrassing.
I'm loving this!
That, for me, is the most
iconic bit of the show.
That's the bit… I've got
that saved on YouTube.
Hello, and welcome to
Sex Education Unpacked.
I'm your esteemed host,
Gena-Mour Barrett.
Now, let's be honest.
We were left with
some pretty big questions
at the end of season two.
Will Maeve find out
about the deleted voicemail?
Who's going to be
the new headteacher?
And will Otis
ever get a new jacket?
Honestly,
that is my main question.
I'm not going to spoil it
for you
but, if you haven't binged
the new series yet,
you might want to do it now
before someone else does.
Now, one of the big themes
of this season is
mental health.
Whether we're talking about
Jackson struggling
with anxiety
or Aimee continuing to work
towards healing her trauma,
the show tackles
some tricky topics
when it comes
to matters of the mind.
In this episode,
we're going to be discussing
why being open
about these topics
is so important,
not just in Sex Ed,
but in our own lives, too.
Joining me today are
Sex Education creator,
Laurie Nunn,
plus musician and actor,
Jordan Stephens,
writer and advocate,
Kenny Ethan Jones,
and founder of
Black Minds Matter,
Agnes Mwakatuma.
Jordan, Kenny and Agnes,
welcome to the
Sex Education Unpacked sofa.
-Hello!
-Hello.
In season two,
we saw Jackson struggle
under the pressure
of his sporting career,
leading him to
experience anxiety,
which is something
he opens up to Cal about
in season three.
Let's watch a clip.
So, why did you go
all woozy today?
It's anxiety.
I've always had it.
But it's been
pretty bad recently.
I think,
now I'm not swimming,
I haven't got a routine.
And I get triggered
by the most random stuff.
It's ok. I have anxiety too,
so I get it.
But what was the trigger
this time?
Just school.
I was thinking,
if I don't swim anymore
and I'm not head boy,
and you might have heard
I'm not very good at acting,
then just who the hell am I?
Like, maybe I don't care
about anything enough.
Woah. You're 17.
You don't have to have it
all figured out.
This is not the message
the world is giving me.
Maybe try just being
Jackson Marchetti
for a little bit.
Alright, I'll try.
There's an interesting line
there from Cal:
"You're 17. You don't have
to have it all figured out."
Do you think that,
sometimes,
our mental health
can be impacted
by the pressure
to have everything sorted?
Oh my God, yeah.
I feel like
it's getting worse.
There's more of
an expectation to be
earning a lot of money,
to be the most beautiful,
to be…
to have a total purpose,
and it's, yeah,
poisoned, I suppose,
our ability to
feel ok with just
allowing,
giving ourselves some time.
I honestly think
the feeling of inadequacy
might be at
an all-time high.
Because we're constantly
in touch with
examples of lives that
we compare ourselves to.
-Social media.
-Yeah. Social media and--
I think you get that a lot.
A lot of our clients are
finding it incredibly hard,
especially during
a time like the pandemic,
like seeing people achieve
so much
and then feeling like
you haven't done anything
in a year.
That pressure is a lot
for a lot of people.
There are also these,
kind of,
accepted limitations
that aren't even
necessarily true,
so, again, for example,
the age you're expected
to have certain things.
Maybe be able to
get a house,
have a relationship, kids.
Yeah, there are all these
ideas of
where you should be,
when, in reality, you know,
everybody's life path is
different.
What they're able to
achieve,
depending on their
circumstances, is different,
and the dream is for people
to be ok with that.
Kenny, for you,
how has your relationship
with your mental health
changed over time?
It's been through
so many different stages.
When I was younger, one of
the things I commonly said
was I just want to be happy.
And I didn't know
what that meant
because, like you said,
there were
so many expectations
of what happiness
and success kind of meant.
But, as I got older,
it was more about
being at peace with myself
and my decisions.
And just being, like,
content in who I am
and my identity and,
kind of,
how the world views me
as a trans man.
When you're subjected to
transphobia and racism,
it's hard to navigate
as well as
just being a teenager
and navigating
those normal things.
So I've got really strict
with myself
in terms of boundaries
that I set
to protect my mental health.
That's probably been
the biggest change
over the years.
-Boundaries are essential.
-So essential.
I feel like maintaining
good mental health
is a mixture of boundaries
and doing things
that bring you joy.
For me, it's like stepping
away from conversations
that I don't want to be in,
not giving energy to people
that I don't want to
give it to,
taking time to just go
for a drive or a bike ride,
and just doing little things
that bring me joy,
like playing with my dog.
It looks different
for everybody.
Yeah, absolutely.
-Self-care.
-Yeah.
The word "boundaries" seems
to resonate with all of you.
What's been the biggest
learning for any of you?
Maybe I can start with you,
Agnes.
In terms
of your mental health
and your own
mental health journey.
One of the biggest learnings
has been
that is really takes
a village.
That I can't do it
on my own.
I think surrendering
to accepting the fact that,
if I need to get through
some tough times,
I'm going to need
some people around me
to help me get through that.
Leaning how to trust.
Learning how to love.
Learning how to listen.
And allowing other people
in.
-Love that.
-I love that, too.
Sometimes it helps
to write down
what you want to say first.
I'm not good at writing.
Or you can ask the other
person to close their eyes
whilst you talk to them.
Sounds stupid.
What I'm saying is
it might help you
think more clearly about
what you want to say
if you don't feel observed.
It's just a suggestion.
I'm going now.
You should wear
your normal clothes again.
That top makes your neck
look very long.
I think boundaries have been
my most recent
accomplishment
in terms of self-care
and self-preservation.
I often say yes
quite quickly to things
because I'm excitable.
I'm like a little chocolate
labrador, you know?
And I love
caring for others,
which is not a bad thing,
but it's important
to understand
that you do actually need to
take care of yourself first.
Not to an extreme. All of
this is in moderation.
You sort of touched on it
a little bit here
for my next question,
which is, if you feel
comfortable to share,
what are some of your own
coping strategies
if you're having
a bad mental health day?
I have an emergency
state of health list
that I have on my phone,
so any time it gets
to a point
where I'm really unable to
take care of myself…
Things like reach out
to one person
and tell them how I feel,
buy microwave noodles,
and things like that,
because I don't tend to
cook foods
because I don't want to
take care of myself,
but I need to eat…
-So you can quickly--
-Yeah. Quickly make.
So just being smart with
how I know my body reacts.
Even small things like
making sure that I shower
or brush my teeth
because, when you're
in a bad, bad place,
that's the first thing
to go.
Do you know what I mean?
Other things like making
sure I go for walks.
I try to plan as much
self-care in that day
as possible, so that…
I feel like if you fill your
days with more good things,
slowly, but surely,
you'll start to feel better.
I feel like if you don't
invest into good habits,
all you're doing is kind of
sitting in the same place
and I don't think
that helps.
I feel like that just
helps you spiral.
I think, for me,
it's knowing my triggers.
I know that,
if I'm going through really
bad mental health,
I know the first thing
that I pick up is
either going to make me
spiral
or it's going to help me.
So I just ensure that
the first thing
that I start doing
is actually good
for my body.
Whether that means starting
with a healthy meal
that means
I'm very unlikely going to
spiral into something else,
whereas if I order
McDonalds and Deliveroo,
that means
McDonalds and Deliveroo
until the day
that I feel better.
It just becomes too much.
Or if it's one glass of
wine, then it's two bottles.
You know?
There's no in-between.
So I just have to
make sure that
the first thing that I do
is good for me,
otherwise that's it.
It's a downward spiral.
You sort of touched on this
a little bit earlier
when you mentioned
social media,
because people
obviously talk a lot about
mental health pressures
that come from
living our lives online.
Do any of you find social
media can have an impact
on your personal
mental health?
-Yeah, definitely.
-Yes.
Kenny, you offered
an emphatic yes.
Could you elaborate on that?
Honestly, like, there's
just no space for nuance.
You can't talk about
the grey on social media.
You can't explain that
in a caption.
And so,
you either find yourself
swinging left or swinging
right in situations,
and I feel like it's easy
to lose yourself in that.
Because I'm a person
who really respects the grey
and wants
the difficult conversation
and to actually get to
the bottom of things
and not just agree
for the sake of agreeing.
And you can't do that
on social media.
Again, it goes back
to boundaries
and thinking, you know,
making sure that
I stand strong
in my personal opinion
and not being swayed
by the conversation
or because
it's more popular.
-Do you know what I mean?
-Or the urgency.
-Yeah.
-Everyone to react to stuff.
To react. Absolutely.
I haven't even had a chance
to even catch up
on what's going on.
And, also, you shouldn't
speak about things
that you don't know about.
Agnes,
can you tell us a bit about
setting up
Black Minds Matter
and the specific issues that
young, black people
might have
when it comes to
speaking out?
There is this stigma
that exists
in the black community.
I don't like
talking about it too much
because,
at the end of the day,
we have a right
to have the stigma.
We've been failed
so many times
by the healthcare system
that you can't blame people
for having a reluctance
to speak on stuff.
However,
in a lot of black,
especially African,
families,
children are not awarded
the space to be listened to
as much as possible.
And we also have
this tendency,
especially
if you're religious,
to take your problems
to God.
And no one else.
So it can be really
difficult for children,
especially children
who are experiencing
modern-day issues,
issues that
African parents are
just not used to
talking about.
It can be incredibly
difficult for them
to even be willing to open
up to their own parents.
And, sometimes,
we have clients
who, for example,
apply for therapy
and they don't have
a safe space
to discuss their problems.
And that is just so sad
because the service is
there,
but these kids don't feel
comfortable talking
because mum or dad is
in the other room.
And that's something that
I think, as a community,
we really need to talk
more about.
So, why did you go
all woozy today?
It's anxiety.
I've always had it.
But it's been
pretty bad recently.
I think,
now I'm not swimming,
I haven't got a routine.
And I get triggered
by the most random stuff.
It's ok. I have anxiety too,
so I get it.
So, we know things
are changing slowly,
but how would you all
like to see
the conversation around
mental health going forward?
What more needs to be done?
Agnes, I'd love to go to
you first for this one.
I think we need to get
more comfortable with
talking about
serious mental health.
Everyone's talking about
anxiety and depression,
but as soon as conversations
about schizophrenia,
psychosis, PTSD,
severe PTSD, I mean…
Aimee, bless her,
couldn't even get on a bus
after what had happened.
Everyone kind of
shies away from that.
And, when you look at
black people, for example,
we're seven times
more likely to
be diagnosed with psychosis.
It's time that
we start talking about
you know, those triggers
and what that means,
and stop completely, like,
demonising it
in the black community
because we've had it
time and time again,
how people kind of assume,
for example, that
someone is possessed,
for example.
Just kind of
changing the languages
and the ways that we talk
and describe people
that suffer from
severe mental health.
I think that that is
definitely the one big thing
that I would like to
see change.
I think
it's organisations for me.
Like Black Minds Matter.
I would love to see
more charities
and organisations like that
because I feel like, you
know, as a black trans man,
I want to talk to someone
who's either black or trans
because they're going to
have more understanding of
my lived experience,
so connecting there
and making sense of
my lived experience
and just, like, guiding me
on a good journey
and making me more positive
and all those things.
I just think
it's reliant on, like…
Because, I'll be honest,
if I'm talking to
a white person,
sometimes we just don't have
the same experience.
And so they don't understand
and I spend so much of
my time educating them
to get them to the point
where they even understand,
and it's like I don't want
to spend my days educating.
I just want support
and help.
And so I think it's,
yeah, just more specific
charities and organisations
to help
more marginalised groups.
And the intersections of
all of those
marginalised groups also.
So, yeah.
I'd really love to see that.
It's unacceptable
at this point
that there isn't, like,
a holistic approach
to schooling, either.
I think this can start
a lot earlier.
There is a massive, massive,
massive elephant in the room
there too in school,
where there is absolutely no
reason why you shouldn't be
educated about your own body
and the people around you
when you're developing.
It's insane to me.
There are reports…
I remember reading something
about a school in Harlem
that replaced detention
with meditation
and the
behavioural discrepancies
changed dramatically in that
because you're not
punishing someone,
you're not forcing them
into a space where…
You're actually
allowing them to
communicate
with their own bodies.
It is beyond comprehension
that
that isn't already a thing.
This was fantastic,
honestly. Thank you so…
Honestly,
Jordan, Kenny, Agnes,
thank you so much.
-Thank you.
That was great.
Agnes, thanks for staying
on the
Sex Education Unpacked sofa.
We've also been joined
by the woman behind it all,
Laurie Nunn.
-Laurie, hello!
-Hi.
In season three,
we see Aimee continue
to heal from the trauma
of being sexually assaulted
on the bus.
She goes to therapy, learns
to love her body again
and begins to engage
with feminism.
Let's see her in action.
Sorry.
I just find it hard to talk
about it sometimes.
That's ok.
We don't have to talk about
anything you don't want to.
I just want to
be the old me again.
Well, you may never be
the old you, Aimee.
But that's ok.
As human beings,
we are constantly changing
and developing.
And,
by processing this trauma,
you may gain clarity
on the event itself,
and we can move you towards
healing the relationship
with your body again.
Would you like that?
Yeah, I'd like that.
Laurie, when thinking about
this storyline,
were you inspired by wider
movements such as Me Too?
The story for Aimee
series two strand
came from
a really personal experience
in my own life.
So, I was sexually assaulted
on a local bus
and I knew that that was
something that I wanted to
kind of explore
through writing the show
and I knew that Aimee was
an interesting character
to do that with.
And then,
moving into series three,
it felt really important
to me that her strand
just didn't fall away,
and that it…
I wanted to show that,
you know,
if you've experienced
trauma,
but, particularly,
sexual trauma,
it's not something
that just disappears.
It's something that you…
you know,
continue to carry with you
throughout your life.
And, yeah, in terms of
the Me Too movement,
I don't think that it
necessarily, like,
inspired me to write it,
but I think that
that movement has given
myself and so many women,
like, the confidence and
the tools and the language
to reflect on
our experiences and say:
"I think this is actually
a really important story
and I want to tell it
and I think it, like,
deserves to be
seen and spoken about."
One of the things
that I love so much
about the way
that Aimee's storyline
happens in season three
is that it doesn't just
fall away.
I think that,
in other shows,
perhaps it would still be
present within flashbacks
or things like that,
but you actually see
Aimee go to therapy
and that is a really
important change
and moment
for that character.
Agnes, it's interesting
what Aimee says
about wanting
to be the old her.
Why can sexual trauma be
so difficult
for women to move forward
from?
One of the annoying things
about sexual assault
is it starts so early.
But we're not educated
enough
about the different forms
of sexual assault.
Like, I remember going to,
sort of like,
an under 16s nightclub
and having the bouncer
grope me as I was walking in
and I didn't think
that was a bad thing.
But I'm under 16.
He should not be doing that.
And it took me a very
long time to accept that.
I was in this, kind of like,
long period of denial
that, you know,
it wasn't that bad.
I was wearing a short skirt.
You know, like, he deserved
access to my body.
I think it's just difficult
because, a lot of the time,
we're in denial
for such a long time
and then having to
just accept that,
you know, somebody has
violated you is difficult.
And then having
to accept that
it's going to be a part
of you for a very long time
is even harder.
I think you're so right,
as well.
Like, sometimes
it feels like things happen
and then, by the time you've
realised it was a thing,
you're like:
"Oh. Is it too late for me
to even address it?"
Like:
"Should I just continue?"
You're absolutely right
about that.
Do you feel that,
if you hadn't smiled at him,
he wouldn't have assaulted
you?
I don't know.
Had you smiled at
strangers before?
And had that led to
them assaulting you?
Listen to me, Aimee.
What that man did to you
on the bus
has nothing to do
with your smile
or your personality
and is only about him.
And it is absolutely
not your fault.
What advice
would you give to someone
who is at the beginning
of that journey
of understanding
an experience
that's happened to them,
such as Aimee's storyline?
I think
the most important thing is
finding people
that you trust
and people
who are professionals,
who understand
the various forms of trauma,
especially sexual assault.
Because the
most dangerous thing that
you can ever do to yourself
during, like, you know,
a journey of healing is
share your story
with somebody that is
not quite versed
on the topic
and, also, that could
possibly gaslight you.
Laurie,
was it important for you
to have
Aimee go to therapy
and actually seek out help
and have that conversation?
Yeah.
I feel like in,
you know, in series two,
she really gets the sort of
catharsis and the help
from her peers, from
her female friends in, like,
realising that she's not
alone in that experience.
That, like, other women
in her life have had
similar things happen.
To me, it felt like…
it felt, like,
really important to say
to anyone
that's watching the show
that has been through
something like that
that there is a point
at which,
if you're still carrying
those, like,
negative feelings towards
yourself and your own body,
that you should seek
professional help.
And that there is,
like, a lot of
services out there
that can give you, you know,
the tools to, like,
move forward.
Yeah, absolutely.
Agnes, Laurie. Thank you
so much for joining me.
Now, I need a break.
I'm sweating. I'm tired.
My throat's dry.
My lips are not dry because
they've got gloss on them.
It's hard work doing
this presenting job,
so I'm handing
the presenting reigns
over to Jordan
for the next segment,
where he's going to
quiz Laurie
on the making of
Sex Education.
I'll see you back in
the games room afterwards.
Thanks, Gena.
-Laurie, how are you?
-Good.
We've talked a lot about
the different mental health
themes
that run through
season three.
How do you go about deciding
what journeys you want
the characters to take?
To be honest, like,
with the characters,
it's really just working out
what feels the most,
kind of like, organic
and dramatic in terms of
where they're going to
head next,
and then the issues tend to,
sort of, present themselves.
So, it's, like…
With Jackson, for example,
with his anxiety,
we know that that is
baked into his character
and that's, like,
part of who he is.
And then that
really affects, you know,
the different storylines
that he has.
So I'm always thinking about
that,
I guess, when I'm writing.
You know, we're into
three seasons, now,
which is, you know,
a long period of time
and I think, more than ever,
conversations are,
like, rapidly shifting.
Are you influenced
by the conversation
in wider society
in terms of the individual
struggles that they have?
I try not to,
sort of, come at the stories
from that, sort of,
perspective.
I think because the show is
about teenagers
and the teenage experience
is so universal,
those issues just tend to,
sort of, present themselves
in quite an organic way
with the characters.
-Right.
-Yeah.
And then I work with a team
of really great writers
and it's everybody's
own personal experiences.
Yeah, they're coming in
with different examples.
If anyone asks,
the wobbly bits aren't
mistakes because…
all vulvas are unique.
Good lad!
They'd better not
be squished.
But one thing that
Sex Education does
incredibly well
is deal with
these topic matters
that are, you know,
predominantly quite heavy
but, I suppose,
a way of making it
enjoyable or accessible,
is probably the better word,
is balancing the darkness
with light, you know?
So how do you go about
striking that balance?
Yeah, so my favourite type
of writing is
really anything that has,
like,
both happy and sad.
-Comedy and tragedy.
-Emotions in it.
And I love it when it's
actually in the same scene
or in the same character
because I feel like that's
true of, you know,
being a human, I guess.
That it's complicated
and messy
and funny and sad
at the same time.
When I'm writing, I'm always
trying to think of
the comedy first
because I think…
that's then how I'm able to
then talk about the, sort
of, darker and more, like,
dramatic things because
maybe I've sort of lured
people in through the jokes
and then, you know, I get to
tell a storyline
like Aimee in the bus
in series two which is,
you know,
I guess,
darker or more serious.
You have to earn the right.
Well, Laurie. Thank you.
-Wicked to speak to you.
-You too.
Jordan, I feel so relaxed
after that break.
Thank you so much.
We've ditched the sofas.
The aprons are on.
That means one thing:
it's time for
our after-school challenge.
This one is for all you
Food Tech fans out there.
Inspired by Aimee's foray
into the world of baking,
you're going to have
three minutes
to design your very own
Sex Education themed cake.
You've got icing.
You've got sprinkles.
You've got some questionable
supermarket cakes.
And you've got a brief
that is
extremely open
to interpretation,
so kind of just do
what you want.
I'm going to give us
three minutes.
Oh, mate.
Oh, shoot!
We've got three minutes.
Three, two, one, go!
-How do you…
-I'm just going to start.
Listen, I don't know what…
-How…
-Shall I just do this?
Do you put these nozzles
on this, or…? Oh, yeah!
Icing to, like…
Don't… No, no.
Don't add that.
Oh, that's good.
Shall we just use the icing,
actually?
Yeah.
Right. You have to draw,
like, the insides.
Oh. Maybe we just do, like…
And then use the icing
on top to…
Yeah, but…
How do you do that
with the faces?
I can do that! And then
you do the other thing.
-Really? Are you sure?
-Yeah.
Truthfully, no, but I feel…
Yeah.
Ok. Alright.
But I was going to do
a real beautiful--
Alright, yeah. You do that.
Go in. And I'll top it up.
You're alright.
-We could use this as--
-This won't come out.
Fuck!
They've already got it out.
Oh, yes.
Maybe a cherry. That's good.
Yeah, a cherry.
-Ok.
Was that…
Was that supposed to go
around the whole thing?
No, because you have to
leave the bit underneath to…
Oh, to say it. Ok, yeah.
Ok. One minute gone.
Oh my gosh, what?
-Wait, do the faces.
-Ok.
-Wait, this is insane.
-I know.
Lord, have mercy.
You're doing the faces,
right?
-Yeah. I'm trying!
-Alright.
That's really good.
-Oh my God. That is…
-They've done a whole…
And maybe we could just make
this a little bit thicker.
Look. There we go.
This is embarrassing.
I'm loving this.
Oh my God.
This is brilliant!
Wait. It's going down.
It's sinking.
Oh, then maybe we could use
these as well.
One minute and five seconds
left.
And this could, like,
represent your identity
-Yeah.
-because it's brown.
There's got to be
an easier way to write this!
This is too thick.
Ok.
I'm writing it with this.
Well, less than a minute
left to go.
-What do you mean?
-Ok, you…
This is the worst idea
of a challenge!
No, this is…
-Oh…
-It's fine.
-Ok.
-No, that's not…
It won't come… I don't know
what to write it with.
Do you know what you should
do instead? This first.
-Let's do this.
-Oh, yeah.
How long have we got left?
Check-in time.
Oh, ok. Sorry. Yeah.
-How long have we got?
-We've got 30 seconds left.
Fuck! Oh, Lord.
I don't know
why I didn't do that before.
Yeah. It's…
It's… Ok.
It's falling apart!
Oh, maybe we should do it,
like, this way.
Yeah. Let's do it like that.
It's more…
-Sprinkles.
-Yeah.
You add the sprinkles.
You…
What can you do?
What's this?
We need some more blood.
-How do you…
-Put that down.
We've got five seconds!
Four. Three.
Yes!
One. Stop, stop!
Oh my God. What is that?
What is going…
Oh, wow.
This is a masterpiece.
I'm so proud of this.
It's been a great time.
Please can you explain
the thought process
behind your cake?
-I'd love to hear that.
-Ok.
So, the idea was
that we wanted to draw,
basically, a vagina,
but also
with an enlarged clitoris
because, as a trans man,
part of taking testosterone
is
you grow
an enlarged clitoris.
And, essentially,
this is the orgasm here,
but the blood represents,
well,
the red represents
period blood.
So, we're having sex
on your period
and then we've added in
some sprinkles here.
Which is something you're
not taught enough in school.
You're made to feel like
your periods are disgusting,
but you still have every
right to please yourself
even on your period,
so that's the explosion.
Yes.
And we've used many colours
and been artistic as much as
we could.
-You smashed it!
-Thank you very much.
Amazing. Amazing.
It is good.
Jordan, tell us about
what we were going for here.
So, what we were going for
is,
you know in a swimming pool
there's the
no petting signs?
So I was trying to do,
like, a little red, yeah?
And then
there's people kissing.
Yeah. That was the plaque
that we did.
Icing is, like,
fucking hard to use.
-It is.
-So that didn't happen.
And then, basically,
with the excitement
an elation of finishing,
I thought: "Fuck it.
Fuck my idea."
Threw everything else on it
and now it's just
a representation of
the chaos we all feel inside
in our late teens.
Do you know what?
I'm not going to lie.
That's not bad.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I thank you very much. And
it continues into adulthood.
I was going to say this is a
difficult one to judge, but…
It is hard to judge. It is.
Is it? Is it?
You're on my fucking team.
The cakes are both so unique
in their own special way.
I am going to give it to
Kenny and Agnes.
Thank you so, so much.
Amazing. You do deserve it.
You do deserve it.
Don't eat all that cake
at once.
Next up,
we're handing the mic
to the people
who really matter:
the Sex Education fandom.
We've got some of
the biggest fans of the show
with some burning questions
for the Sex Ed cast.
Let's take a look.
Hello,
cast of Sex Education.
My name's Maya
and my question is
if you could have an animal
for a pet,
and it doesn't matter
whether they're domesticated
or wild,
what would it be?
And I love the show.
-I mean, dogs are great.
-You have a dog, don't you?
I do have a dog called Jim,
and he's great.
He's very loud.
I'm trying to think of…
Recently,
you know pandas
have been taken off
the endangered species list?
-I would have to…
-Panda.
Or a sloth.
Ok. I'll have the panda.
You can have the sloth.
I'll have
what you're having.
-We'll go on play dates.
-At the zoo?
Yes.
Hello there!
My name is Nilhe
and I'm from India.
My question for
the cast of Sex Education is
that if you were living
in Moordale in real life,
which character do you think
you would be best mates with
or, you know,
hang out with the most?
Mr. Hendricks.
-Right?
-Yeah.
-He's so funny.
-Constantly entertained.
Constantly.
That's such a good one.
Ok, I think Joe
from the caravan park.
Joe and Cynthia.
Not Joe and Cynthia,
-Jeffrey.
-Jeffrey!
Oh, yeah. That's another
one. That is a good one.
Hey there,
cast of Sex Education.
My name is Nick.
I am from Maryland
in the United States
and I'm a huge, huge fan
of Sex Education.
I love everything that
you guys have done with it.
If I could just have one
question to ask you guys,
it would definitely be
if you have a favourite…
if you have a favourite prop
or a favourite set piece,
whether it's from the school
or someone's bedroom
or the house.
What is it and why?
Thanks and I love you guys.
Ruby's car.
If that counts as a prop,
which I believe it does.
That is definitely
my favourite prop.
100%.
The only thing I could
think of that I liked…
There was just loads of,
like, penises on set
that had nothing to do with
me at all
that I just always liked.
Which is
the most iconic scene
from Sex Education
for you and why?
It's so random,
but I love Mr. Hendricks,
so I think my favourite part
of the scene
in the series is just, like,
when he's practising
with the band
and he's going over
the moves
and he's like: "Up, up,
twist, over" and all that.
I loved that bit.
And, like, his little beef
with Quentin.
That, yeah, that, for me,
is the most iconic bit
of the show.
That's the bit… I've got
that saved on YouTube.
I go back
and watch it occasionally.
Laurie, Jordan,
Kenny and Agnes,
thank you all for joining me
for this episode of
Sex Education Unpacked.
Sadly,
it's time to say goodbye.
I'll see you soon
and don't forget to watch
Sex Education season three.